just navigating the first weekend of the
six nations will be tricky so many
borders being crossed and so many
different sets of covered rules
once you cross the channel you find
italy traveling to france the two
countries that have taken the hardest
lines
a super green pass is needed to get into
public venues in italy a vaccine pass is
mandatory to in france no exceptions not
even for those playing
most of the squads are totally
vaccinated but not england
i'm not a doctor
i don't i don't you know i don't ask tom
show me your vaccination station status
that's not part of the selection
criteria um so it's not something that
concerns me it's not something i'm in
control of
but when we work out what you need to
have to get into france and if there are
players
eligible or staff eligible then we'll
find replacements
after two years of playing in near empty
stadiums the atmosphere of the six
nations is about to be rekindled
the last couple of years not having the
crowds in the venue has been pretty
pretty strange uh but we are obviously
living in
strange times and yeah i think the best
we can do
is obviously being uh
conscious that uh observing the re
observing these rules
we will help us going out of this
current situation
then i think it's going to be it's going
to be an awesome six nations
former england prop victor abugu now
runs his own travel firm taking fans to
the six nations he's desperate to get
going again
in terms of the players
it's it's a very clear-cut role if
you're not vaccinated
you're not going to get into italy
you're not going to get into france
um fans you're not going to get into
italy you're not going to get into
france
so you have to get vaccinated if you
want to go to those places if you choose
not to be vaccinated
then
it's a non-starter
wales had a positive cov test on day one
of their preparation camp it will be a
running theme as the six nations and
their fans return to the fray
tom parmenter sky news